you know what I loved about you uh the
last time you came you brought uh you
brought me a hat right but you brought
me um like the ones you just give away
you didn't bring me the new era and you
were like yo next time I see you I'm
gonna bring you the new era one and I
was like that'd be sweet because I my
big head can't fit in this and I've seen
you seven times since then so yeah um
what size hat you wear seven and a half
I got a donut oh yeah I wear seven and a
half look me and you both got Noggins
huh yeah and we we we're ahead of our
class we are don't Thugs-N-Harmony
you know
did you ever get made photo for having a
[ __ ] Dome scheme that's dumb Thugs
and Harmony ahead of my class [ __ ]
you know I got I got a lot on my brain
from my head you know like a [ __ ] I
don't know man you got you got that I
got like you got that hit [ __ ]
something was going on up there yeah I
think my parents [ __ ] me up when I was
a kid or something yeah like like my
head never reformed after I was born you
know like yeah yeah you you definitely
got appear like newborn baby head
[Laughter]
I still got my soft spot up here it's
like a little salt that's why I always
wear a hat bro no no I mean like you
know you always wear a hat too but you
know I'm you know I'm good
I'm cool my head's just really you gotta
[ __ ] it you got something going on up
there yeah I got it I think y'all got a
noggin you know I definitely had my
class you know but yeah so what's up
with my [ __ ] hats
just like you have me on the Morton's
dinner from three years ago when we when
we
hmm
I guess people from the bay don't pay
their bets oh God no bro every time I'm
like bro let's go be like oh next week
I'm like all right okay